foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
it's recording
recording James Gordon hiding
I know you're gonna do that dude this is
cool to do with the ehi after you say
something we were talking about how
after you say something offensive or
mean or whatever you say okay you could
go like this too you said something
offensive uh you know you look
particularly fat today
and you're bringing the hands like under
your neck like this oh okay it seems
terrible no it's good trust me it's
disarming I won't trust you on that okay
well welcome to another episode of
Lifeline it's episode
4685. we're really cranking them up yeah
um but Matt is in gay prison with that
shirt no dude it's styling it's styling
Waldo dude come on it would be amazing
if that's what you had in in gay prison
just so [ __ ] so Pimpin pimping in gay
prison put zip it all the way up what's
it look like
um
now the thing about now the thing about
now me wearing this now is I wore this I
think I wore this on the very first
episode of like I think you did yeah and
it's just like you know it's not like
that but if you say it is exactly like
this wow and here he comes oh don't mind
if I did ruined it sneaking out I was
tiptoeing like Ace Ventura when he's
trying to go see the the dolphin or
whatever
yeah that was like that how about when
people tiptoe and make more noise than
they would if they just straight up
walked you know oh man like on creaky
floors they're just like
yeah yeah and if you walked it would
just be yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah yeah yeah so I uh so what's
going on man rained a lot in L.A that
sucks it rained a lot and worst weather
man I I'm happy it rained I used to hate
the rain but now I like it poetry Haiku
because there's a [ __ ] Mega drought
ruined it nope Mega drought would never
be in any Palm that is the well I'm not
giving this is not spoken word I'm just
talking talking like it is
so there was a mega drought
in my garden was thirsty Garden was my
garden was thirsty my garden was dying
of thirst what's that my garden was
dying of thirst
my garden was dying of thirst
whisper the whisper on thirst so bad
dude well I want to watch So I Married
next murder again she was a thief you
gotta be Leaf she left with my hot and
my cat
dude who is it again who played that
Mike Myers dude wait that was him who
did that one though yeah it wasn't yeah
yeah that's why I thought it was someone
else who did that part I know Mike Myers
you're thinking about Anthony lapalia
who's also hilarious oh my God he was so
funny in that he's really funny I love
him he's a fan of mine so anyway
um that's a good fan of yours to have he
was dude he was he is he is yeah and uh
he's Australian and no one because he
looks like an absolute guy from the
Bronx or Queens yeah two things about
entertaining the Paul there three things
okay he's Australian but looks like he's
from the Bronx from Queens so nobody
knows he's destroying yeah uh second is
he nobody knows this put him up on the
screen because look at him because look
at him but he's not here but you know
what I'm saying yeah you know what I'm
saying I know okay but oops okay we know
what he looks like so that's one number
two is that he
you wouldn't know it by looking at most
of his work but he's hilarious oh I know
he's very funny and the third thing is
you really wouldn't know it by the kind
of TV he does but he's like he's like he
came up in theater he's like a big
theater I buy that so I was like he's
just Pimpin pimping
all over the place wow okay wow uh so
he's so comfortable with that picture of
the way dude he is he is so from New
York how is he up I don't know also
lapalia I know I know I know that well
that's the real thing that sells it but
it'd be like if DeNiro was like oh you
know it's like
um you know I really like um
what's the [ __ ] thing he says uh I'm
not talking to you yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
talking to you you're talking to me yeah
that's it yeah
am I talking to you wow absolutely
ruined it it's just so insecure am I
talking to you or who isn't talking to
you is am I
um yeah anyway
so gay prison huh see you no I don't
think so oh well I think it's I think
it's stylish Waldo okay and I don't
think it's gay prison okay although I
don't it's not like you know I mind gay
prison because like I'm like I'm not
homophobic I would mind gay people just
correcting you I would mind any person
really any person yeah what prison just
prison would be bad president cut me off
again you're cutting me off just
non-stop today are we gonna do it that
way or
I just didn't get notified if we're
doing that just that's good to know
she's gonna cut me off all the time
uh sign a treatment now such a child you
know dude well look good oh okay well
you know when your hair is in a good
place and you know your hair's in a good
place you don't want to move so you're
just like
then the Batman man it's a good thing
for me is though my hair's never uh in a
good place so I can just move my head uh
all I want you know my hair is
my hair is never in a good place
the worst [ __ ] poem of all time
um so anyway you guys it's Lifeline
Episode 600
775. dude mads Mickelson or whatever
that guy yeah what about him I love him
man he was in a [ __ ] comedy movie I
looked at the other day so far in a
comedy movie yeah
I looked at yeah like an old lady says
it seriously I looked at one of my
programs and Mad Max was in it was it
the drinking movie yep no I don't know
what's that well I don't know what's the
movie you saw oh not the drinking movie
no uh it was a foreign movie okay okay
well he's farming what's the name of the
movie I don't know
okay well that you brought up something
that we can't even discuss no we can't
but I do love mads he's another guy
who's funny and he doesn't seem like he
is yeah that's true he was on a flight
once he also he also commits
so hard to the roles that he's playing I
know like he's in that [ __ ] movie uh
that Nicholas winding record movie that
nobody saw uh the one that's in black
and white
he plays like a crazy crazy Viking and
he uh uh uh anyway he's just like it's
like the bloodiest [ __ ] movie ever uh
what the [ __ ] is that in that movie dude
uh Rio
Rio the cartoon yeah yeah no is it real
uh Ice Age that's right Ice Age yeah so
um no but I I saw he was on a plane of
mine oh he was on a plane with me and he
he was sitting like maybe one behind me
and I would I I would look back and like
that's the [ __ ] guy then I didn't
really know his name you know it was
like years ago I was like that's that
[ __ ] guy that's the bad guy in the
James Bond movie all right yeah yeah and
he was reading a script and he was just
like reading the script like this and
the light was on it I mean it was so
cinematic nighttime flight and he was
just like turning it over and I was like
he's so I mean maybe this is [ __ ] me
but like you know succumbing to
Hollywood but I was like dude he's so an
evil villain yeah he's yeah totally I
mean he's a great actor you know what he
got huge he was always a popular actor
but he what made him huge is that show
he was on was playing Hannibal Lecter oh
yeah that's right playing Hannibal
Lecter probably such a goofy show but
yeah also was he the lead of the [ __ ]
Pusher movies is that was like first
[ __ ] I don't know what that is uh all
right well since nobody knows anything
in his I mean this is literally yeah I'm
willing to help me talk about Nicholson
for nine nine minutes everybody loves
mad though I know but people don't even
know who he is though we show him on the
screen right now and they'd be like oh
yeah that guy
true he's super super
handsome in a weird way how much money
has sex dude it's so quick Valhalla
Rising and this is how he has an orgasm
he goes a kiss
and that's it that's the whole orgasm
that's the whole orgasm but then in a
few minutes like in the shower whoever
he had sex with hears him with the door
closed she hears him off like in the
bathroom just go
hey what's he doing he's just like
getting the energy out
that's ridiculous dude all right it does
um well let's go into some some uh uh
what do you call them
submissions submissions guys let's go
into some submissions and I'm wearing
sweats and I feel bad I'm wearing sweats
why but I'm having a chillaxing I
sometimes I used to feel that way but
now I wear sweats whenever the [ __ ] I
want but yeah but yeah all right let's
do it all right
Sansom put up Matt and Chris this is
Josh from Detroit I was hoping to get a
little bit of advice from you guys so my
wife and I have a dog that we take out
three times a day right
um the issue is though our dog is cute
as hell so everybody always wants a
small talk with us about our dog you
know and tell us about their dogs
um which is normally like totally fine
but we live on the 21st floor of our
apartment and so I've been finding
myself just locked in in an elevator
yeah forced into small talk with people
when I don't always want to like I
generally think of myself as like a nice
person
um and like I don't mind talking with
people but I've just been having the
same conversation over and over and over
and I don't always want to
um but I also don't want to be a dick so
I've found myself in this situation
where I'm like forcing myself to make
small talk and it's kind of driving me
crazy so I was just wondering what do
you guys think I should do should I you
know just continue forcing myself to
smile and talk to these people just
because like that's what a good neighbor
does or should I just give up and be a
dick I don't know what do you guys think
appreciate any animal advice that is so
oh that's so funny I got a good news on
21 floor I got a good one
and I don't mean the [ __ ] small ass
earbuds that people can miss I mean have
the big Honky Tonk [ __ ] headphones
that's a great idea even if even if you
don't own them and they're expensive if
they're good obviously buy a [ __ ] pair
on eBay and they'll have the big Honky
Tonks on both ears and then just like
even if there's no music in it just be
like Bob in your head and talking about
it you know and then if they if they ask
a question just go yes right exactly
that's exactly right yeah yeah
it's exactly right
wow wow feeling your tits okay uh uh
yeah that's a great you know what I'm
saying or if you want to do the earbuds
you can do that and just pretend you're
on the phone yeah yeah yeah okay cool
yeah keep pretending I'm on the phone is
the most the the one I've done the most
I do that without earbuds so you just
look like a crazy guy yeah exactly yep
uh-huh and then they go and they go I go
okay no just indicate that there's like
another person in the room but they're
invisible yeah like what what's the
matter you know the guy here yeah yeah
um yeah honestly uh that's horrible the
living in the 21st floor is incredible
so dude I'm sure that takes sometimes 15
minutes to get downstairs that's that's
too many floors but it's Detroit though
right that's what he said yeah I know so
it's like there's buildings that are go
crazy in Detroit it's like uh buildings
growing it's like you might start on the
third floor book high-rise the JG
Ballard yeah yeah the movie they made a
movie about movies absolutely [ __ ] I
heard the movie was menacingly terrible
and uh menacingly terrible Raves
crystallia menacingly terrible yeah if
you want to see the most menacingly
terrible movie uh yeah really really uh
really bad movie and uh the bookstick
I've read the book okay well let's go I
read the book all right look if you're
that's so annoying so if you're
if you're I think don't live on the 21st
oh if you live on the 21st floor don't
have a dog don't have anything cute but
if you do get headphones even if they're
the chords cut just yeah it doesn't
matter
yeah yeah and then when people ask one
more one more time yeah yeah yeah
foreign
look at this if if a black guy comes
love Mountain but where's my pictures I
love Mountain but where's my pictures
like you're not saying it right there's
nothing in your ears it would be the
weirdest the weirdest thing to
experience you know I love Mountain but
where's my bridges I love my where's my
[ __ ] the problem is if they do say
something you gotta pretend that you
don't hear because if you're like if
you're like that and then you're like
yeah my [ __ ] what's that yeah yeah you
know yeah that's bad it'll ruin it it
gives up the whole [ __ ] thing yeah
bring up my schedule here will you bring
it you weren't even talking you can only
use the oops when you're I'm saying ooh
you're interrupting with your schedule
listen here we go all right I'm gonna be
in Austin March 25th uh I'm going to be
in Minneapolis April 1st I'm going to be
in Columbus Ohio May 6th May 7th I'm
gonna be in Cincinnati Ohio Cincy and
then May 19th I'm gonna be in Boise and
that's how you say it and whoever told
me that was Aaron Paul Aaron Paul told
me he's from there it's Boise so he
would know he came to my Aaron Park in
my last show in Boise and uh now I'm
gonna do another show in Boise is he
always in Boise is that a bigger place
well moving on up in the world is he
always in Boise now like does he live in
Boise no I don't believe so but maybe he
has a place there but he he but I'll
tell you what he's another guy I tell
you what Boise's [ __ ] cool man what
how so how's boys it's like a hip it's
got a Vibe not everybody's there yet
it's coming up it's got cool coffee
shops oh man and it's very nice no you
don't like cool coffee she's like
[ __ ] Coffee Bean you [ __ ] I tell you
what dude I've been off the coffee bean
for a while oh I I do go sometimes oh
the truth comes out I've been going to
this place I don't want to say
don't blow it up and then a peach coffee
is very good too do you like pizza yeah
I do I do like
ETS
um and then but yeah so uh I went to
Boise and it was great it was a good
show uh and Aaron Paul was there with
with his friends uh I love I love that
dude he's such a good he's such a great
guy and he's always been the exact same
amount of good guy I mean we've known
him when he was [ __ ] doing Taco Bell
commercials I know well I did I did a
movie with him when I was 19. I remember
and he was 20 and you know how we always
make fun of everybody yeah and then one
time he was like
he said something I'll never forget it
he was like I don't know what uh he's
like
I don't make fun of people I'm 20. he's
like I'm 20 years old like saying like
he didn't like he didn't like making fun
of him and I felt bad and I always
thought about it anyway what does that
mean one has nothing to do he was saying
like I'm I'm too old for that I'm not in
like you know oh well [ __ ] him we don't
know anymore but no no we love him he's
out dude we love him we love him he's
not we love him and he's right he can
take his tequila and I [ __ ] love that
dude and and I if I drank I drink his
tequila so much
to him let's go to him hey to Aaron Paul
hey just pick that up you know I don't
have a but I don't have it Aaron Paul
there we go we love you Aaron
and Brian Cranston oh wow Brian did I
say it like that Brian Cranston you saw
an Australian just when you said yep I'm
Anthony lapalia yeah
um I am from New York what do you do and
I I don't be Breaking Me balls huh don't
be breaking my balls I tell you right
now I'll take you down matt I'll take
you to massmith and just I'll curb stomp
yeah forget about it
Pista didn't think of it um so yeah
anyway Austin tickets are on sale now
chrislea.com go over there tickets are
[ __ ] flying off the shelf right the
proverbial shelf right the imaginary
shelf there's no shelf it's all virtual
but you know what I mean things are
flying off the proverbial shelf uh so
yeah so go get it you know the good
tickets are gone and they're off the
proverbial shelf right but wow um so
anyway we're doing it we're doing it
we're having a good time and uh do it
live go to matilda.com get private
sessions with me 135 third Pacific Time
Tuesdays and Thursday
Matt okay yeah that's incredibly [ __ ]
terrible it's menacingly terrible is it
menacingly bad I'm interestingly
terrible so what we're going to do is
we're gonna have you guys all in the
comments talk about whether you like it
when I go okay no or if you don't like
it no okay that is a good idea but I
want you to rank top 10 I want you to
rank 10 mats laugh ten minutes most
menacingly terrible or one least
menacingly terrible yeah so if it's a 10
just hit flood it with 10 if you agree
with me if you think it's a five using
usually the positive is the that's why
I'm doing it like that because I think
people are going to be oh you're gonna
try to confuse them you're trying to
stack the deck okay I'm [ __ ] up the
polls okay you know what I realized boss
tweet over we get into another one dude
I'm badass oh [ __ ] really and I'll tell
you why yeah
I'm yadded the [ __ ] up oh is that why no
but I'll tell you why oh you just did I
thought but I'll tell you why on top of
it okay
dude I'm like ridiculously like so I was
standing in a coffee shop the other day
in Denver yeah but I was in Denver right
okay you know I go to coffee shops
wherever yeah for 4 500 people okay so
and
um
had some mental health problems
swallowed it went on stage did my job
was on the brink of Tears the whole time
audience none the wiser kind of Standing
Ovation all good okay that is all good
yeah okay
so all good outwardly not but so we're
all good but when it comes to
I mean sign you get the sign language
you know it's a [ __ ] podcast and the
guy's signing
okay anyway
um
whatever dude so I'm in the coffee shop
getting ready to come home
getting ready to get on top okay to go
to the to the Los Angeles to the plane
to get to the Los Angeles Los Angeles
okay
redundant Los Angeles losses though but
okay so anyway
um
I am standing in the coffee shop line
waiting to get to my what I can watch
out of espresso over ice okay okay but
that's what I get okay but this is about
how you're cool right so far you're not
cool at all okay wait for it gonna quad
shot espresso at a coffee shop in Denver
yeah that's not cool after I bought my
son Silly Putty so
so I don't know how hard so all right
anyway
um it only works on newspapers or not I
need to get a newspapers
anyway uh so
I am there uh and I'm standing there and
I'm waiting and the guy goes Chris Leah
you're going line and I go yeah what's
up he goes hey man big fan I was like oh
thanks and you go and then he stops a
little bit and goes like this
I didn't realize you look so badass no
swear to God didn't happen and I go oh
yeah oh yeah I'm [ __ ] tied it up huh
he goes yeah I didn't know that nope I'm
telling you right now that did not
happen it happened dude which I
understand something you added up what's
interesting you said you realized that
your yeah you help me thank you
girlfriend I
forget what it's like to realize that
because I realized it when I was five
years old
and I have not wavered since I realized
it in in Dad's balls no I realized it in
in Mom's uterus no but that's Bob's been
dead salts first no I since she was born
she's had her eggs that creates new
sperm all the time so I've literally
noted since I was in Mom's uterus I
realized one of her god-given eggs I
hate that I was [ __ ] badass and
that's fine but I realized it in Grandpa
Bam's balls hahaha
what he was doing newspapers in 1920s he
was selling newspapers and [ __ ] right
and he was doing a get your newspapers
on the corner of Times Square and [ __ ]
right and then [ __ ] I was in his
balls like this you know what I'm pretty
[ __ ] badass I'm getting up
yeah no dude you know I realized it like
early early on like uh back
um you know when that Pope were related
to so his cousin were related to the
pope through his cousin
I realized how badass I am in that guy's
[ __ ] balls in the like the 1500s and
the Pub's balls in the pup's cousins
balls I'm badass
well shooting out um all right cool so
it's not really just going to hell so
let's take a uh another guy right now
God just goes like this huh that sucks
and push the hell button so uh let's do
another one here yep
wow
hey what's up though the coolest videos
are sleep live podcast asleep uh what do
you do in your sleeping time oh [ __ ] and
forget about that but
if you're to work a normal job well you
don't hold it steady like what would you
expect hourly
like how many hours would you expect to
get a week and how much would you expect
per hour have you worked if you were to
work a normal job no
that's it you know peace out let me
guess you want Less hours
I'm gonna take a wild guess that this
guy wants a little bit less out gonna
use this podcast to go in and talk to
his boss yeah totally yeah so I don't
know if you're familiar with this so I
don't know if you're familiar because if
you're Brothers
and they said that I should be getting
like 25 an hour yeah and I certainly be
working three hours well I don't even
know dude I haven't done like an hourly
what is he what is he talking he's
saying if you were gonna have like a
regular job me
but like I wouldn't I know man but he's
obviously he's asking to take a leap
with him okay he can't be so [ __ ]
literal I'm literal dude uh okay so he's
asking if we were uh to get a normal job
what would we expect to work in terms of
hours per week and then what do we
expect our wage to be and the answer is
it depends on the [ __ ] job yeah
really ass head yeah ass head get a job
as an asset you'll do really [ __ ]
well so dick uh get a job Judge Judy
would say that why don't you get a job
as an asshad
if it's like if it's working at a
McDonald's I would expect about minimum
wage and I would expect maybe 30 hours a
week I I don't know uh if I was working
as a [ __ ] uh landscaper I don't know
a little bit more a little bit more but
12 an hour more yeah but what's minimum
wage it's more yeah I know so I'll maybe
expect I'm with it
eighteen dollars an hour or it depends
if I was like
yeah if you're talking about just a
regular job in an office though I
actually have no [ __ ] idea yeah uh
where if you need a skill
yeah he ain't your guy right no but I'm
saying if you need a skill
then you get paid more I think if you
just are a body yeah then you get paid
minimum wage or something like that what
is this [ __ ] question it's why it's
called the unskilled labor force it
doesn't mean you can't do [ __ ] it just
means you don't have skills that weren't
a higher paying that's something
the unskilled labor of course yeah I
know yeah oh okay cool
um so expect minimum wage and expect the
uh amount of out the best amount of
hours you could get because then you
want the most amount of money
and also how much do you want to how
many hours a week do you want to work
does he want to work I want us to work
zero hours a week yeah he doesn't want
to ever get out of bed and stop smoking
weed he's also the kind of guy that goes
like this man I'd love to make money in
my sleep yeah right passive income
passive income bro that's what it is
that's what it's all about
he says the words passive income more
than he says the words high in his life
yeah hi he he greets people less often
than he says the words passive income
yeah yeah so it basically open your eyes
more
stop smoking so much weed
I know this isn't the advice you asked
but take whatever the [ __ ] someone's
willing to give you and be happy about
it wow it's amazing how much people work
to work their life away though huh yeah
but from what I understand nobody's got
a [ __ ] job right now nobody wants one
and everybody's poor hmm I think the
solution is all those people who are
poor get a [ __ ] job
it's a Republican no but it's really
[ __ ] uh it's so weird to me that
people want jobs people want money
everybody's broke but there are jobs or
places that they can't [ __ ] they
can't hire anybody like they can't keep
an employee it is weird right I don't
there has to be a reason that I don't
get it I don't get it we'll never get it
hey I don't get it I'll go all right
next one
hi Chris hi Matt my name is Sam I live
in Upstate New York 27 next week these
are my dogs oh my god
um okay so I'm gonna make this really
short my question is should I buy a
house
so in 2020 I got out of relationship me
and him live together in a home that we
picked out for like four years I love an
apartment this is my second year signing
a lease I don't want to live here it's
like right in the middle of like the bar
scene kind of going out
um I feel like an old lady I go outside
and I tell people to be quiet yeah
that's my living room window and there's
like bar seating right outside of it so
sometimes like I work overnight I'm a
nurse I go outside I'm like hey not for
nothing but like let's stop screaming
anyway should I keep renting should I
wait until I find the one and then we
buy a house together should we find the
one and then he has a house and I move
in with him or should I just buy my own
[ __ ] house
like shit's expensive shit's hard I
don't know if that's something that I
should be doing alone hmm
you know but at the same time I would
love that I would love for them to have
a yacht
cute you want a yard for them doggies
here's the thing always if you can
get a house if you can't afford one get
one unless it's in the middle of [ __ ]
like some place where there's like a
nuclear power plant or there's some
[ __ ] poison in the air or whatever
the [ __ ]
it's always a good idea to to buy a
piece of property if you can afford it
don't go over your head but like if you
can afford a piece of property if it's
in a she said Upstate New York I'm
assuming there's like [ __ ] going on
around there she said there's bars and
[ __ ] yeah if you can buy a house in that
area absolutely absolutely [ __ ] do it
and don't wait don't wait you want your
own house because then you can sell it
if you want to move in with another guy
right or another person whatever or if
you want to have them move in you have
that option as well but like you want
your own [ __ ] go get your own renting is
throwing money away if you all know that
if you can buy a house buy it period
always because you you know you'll
probably buy a house and then me to do
next the next week exactly and then but
then that's good you take it slow you
live in the house for two years and then
you move in or whatever the [ __ ] or you
sell that place and move right but I'm
just saying that you then you lose some
money because of the closing costs and
all I mean only if you do that right
away in the first year right right
that's what I'm saying so two years it's
crazy how we agreement right
freeze so
um yeah I think that uh also you'll be
happier because you don't want to live
right outside of the bar you're a nurse
yeah if you're gonna even if you're not
gonna buy move yeah true yeah true and
you got doggies and what'd you say she
was 27 I think did she say it or did I
make that up I think she did so I
thought she said she was 26 27. anyway
that's young you get a house it's your
first house congratulations you'd be
happy yeah and you'll get better sleep
and then also you'll meet a guy soon and
then you'll figure it out and that's
great and maybe you'll meet a [ __ ]
baller dude you know you're a nurse
maybe somebody will come in and be like
I got a kidney stone and you're like oh
[ __ ] that's not that big of a deal
you're gonna have a long life ahead of
you and also guess what I love you oh
wow and we love each other and guess
what oh you're a millionaire had no idea
where are we going I'll sell my house
I'll take care of your darling he does
it like that very sure could be
chauvinistic but also could be
empowering because you're doing what you
want to do right
yeah it could be a lot of things but
just don't live based on things that
might happen in the future you want to
buy a house get a [ __ ] house exactly
rest will work itself out exactly very
cool love your style love your dogs very
cool you got two three gold chains I got
two two bulldogs right all right you
know and so uh but that's great thank
you very much for your um
for your for your video submission
submission yes let's do another one
you're good at it you are good at that
you are good at that why I don't know
you know why because I know people okay
then why'd you ask me uh I want people
to know that Charlie Sheen from
Australia this guy five years together
she's 23. we're really happy together
we're just chilling
um what we find now being together for
five years that at almost every social
setting
people always ask us when are you
getting married when are you having kids
they sort of sang it say it jokingly but
um it's not funny anymore it's been
happening for ages now
um I was just hoping to get some funny
comebacks or clap Backs from yous about
how to deal with it
um yeah she's gonna help me out it'd be
great cheers
when are you getting married when are
you gonna get off my [ __ ] back and
then move on oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my back's
all sweaty why because you're on it
right now I might get no fit yeah that's
okay that's great yeah anything like
that hey what anything that's blunt you
know it's funny and like almost rude but
not rude you know what's insane is I'm
looking at you
I could see your whole body right and it
looks like you're not touching me but at
the same time
you're on my back it's abundantly clear
you're on my back how does it happen get
off it mm-hmm thank you I'm being so
polite at the end I really appreciate
you time and your effort you know
um yeah dude just [ __ ] come up with
the quip that's a good one another one
is
um we've we've had advice like this
similar something similar and we gave
good advice what the [ __ ] was yeah you
can go like this you think of that you
can go like this
what are you doing ah
it's crazy because I'm Googling most
personal thing you can ask somebody
scared of the blue and um
of all the top 10 things
this is this is number one
and I'm looking at you
and I can see you but my back is sweaty
oh boy this again because you're on it
adding both don't get off of my back
and I'm gonna airdrop you this link yeah
that's good and walk away that's good
yeah spin movementality I like how you
did it all in a [ __ ] uh
all in the Australian accent all in the
videos wow what the [ __ ] was Suge Knight
when he was on the MTV dancing all in
the video wow okay
what was the one we had similar [ __ ] it
was we gave her some specific advice
[ __ ] yeah it was probably something
great but I don't know if it wasn't what
we do now but the advice evolves and now
this is this is the advice yeah ask him
about the back the back thing is great
the back thing is great
um and then also you're obviously from
Australia I called it I'm good I have
the gift of fear you know what I mean I
understand what that is or you know what
you could do have women's intuition if
you want to be a little bit more
straightforward like a little less like
cute and Dicky and clever just go then
out I like loud yeah and stare at the
person the now
you can go like this
ask me what are you having kids when are
you having kids my dick is six inches oh
wow yeah I told you that because it's
personal too all right right right okay
so you're smoking dude smoking response
yeah
don't have to
and then keep moving you know
don't have to yeah and then move on to
the dip you know in the corner the dip
like it's at a party you know
do the dip first
yeah I mean that would be my style for
sure dude why do [ __ ] Australians
they why do they have so many tattoos
well Chris I'm Australian if you want to
know the history of Australians I'm
badass I know the history okay well then
but the tattoos are crazy though right
my tattoo it is crazy tattoos My Tattoos
go crazy huh uh yeah Devin Manna does my
tattoos My Tattoos go crazy you see this
[ __ ] though yeah I just [ __ ] pimp and
pimping right here
it out
what do you think I love it well I love
it and then what do you think of this I
love it okay and what do you think of it
no uh the tattoo of a [ __ ] on your dick
it was so weird getting monetized now
great good good
um yeah I think that that's a great idea
and we give great advice and hopefully
you figure it out you're 24 though you
will figure it out and you will have
kids or just say you have them dude [ __ ]
yes I already have three with three
different women so what else do you want
to know I've already got three three
different women of living hell so thanks
for bringing it out what other sensitive
questions you want to ask me that are
going to make me cry
do you want to make me cry yeah all
right next
how you do it hey Chris you read it I'm
getting a water hey Christian Matt love
the show my problem is that I get
incredibly jealous when I see other
people living oh wow living the life I
want to live especially money-wise and
girlfriend wise I get really jealous to
the point where it ruins an entire day
of my life because I keep obsessing
about it so my question is how do I get
rid of this how do you guys control
jealousy well okay think of dude that's
that's obsessive
I have OCD right okay so I get it so you
go ahead and then I'll join afterwards
there's different kinds of jealousy if
you have a girlfriend and you're jealous
of her wait and girlfriend
what
oh oh okay I was just taking it all is
it I'm giving another example of
something that is different than what he
said first okay okay
you good
okay I'm gonna go keep going okay uh so
the first the the kind of jealousy that
you have you see somebody
no you have a girlfriend you see her
floating with someone you're worried
about her getting back together with an
ex whatever hanging out with guys
there's that kind of jealousy but you're
describing a different kind of jealousy
which is like I in my mind much easier
to get rid of than the kind that drives
you crazy about your specific partner
out in the world potentially being with
someone else this guy's talking about
he's jealous of other people's Lifestyle
the the amount of money they have in the
bank uh potentially like maybe like an
attractive girlfriend and girlfriend he
wants dude those people
are not
they might as well not be real they're
outside of your reality they're just
like there it's like looking at
Instagram of course we get jealous of
other people yep like it's right in our
faces not me so there's no there's no uh
if you're seeing it first of all if
you're seeing it online stop going to
the places online that make you feel
those things now if you're seeing it out
in the real world let those
[ __ ] pass you by and then just
like another like a [ __ ] used piece
of toilet paper flush that [ __ ] on the
toilet they're not like right in front
of you in your life dangling their life
like a carrot you're choosing to to
dwell on that instead of dwelling on it
[ __ ] go out there and get the money
get the [ __ ] girl or focus on getting
on a path that gets you those things
he's asking how to combat first of all
dude you have these obsessive intrusive
thoughts and it's terrible and I have
those and I understand and I feel you
know it's different for me what I think
about but I do have those intrusive
thoughts and it sucks and I have OCD and
I and it is really bad sometimes dude
and I say that with no uh
you know
no shame or whatever it's just how it is
and it sucks
um but the way to combat jealousy it was
specifically what you're asking is to
think about the things you're grateful
about grateful for like when I get
caught up I think I used to you know I
used to think about my mom told me this
she was like when you get ah [ __ ]
mama's boy no no when you get ah she was
I forget camera how I felt but she was
like when you get this way oh it was I
couldn't sleep because I was scared when
I was young yeah and I'm a real man you
know me now right well you used to
[ __ ]
me up I know everybody wake up yeah not
scared interests or thoughts okay about
robbers and ghosts and and Freddy
Krueger yep and Freddy Krueger and
aliens and just the quietness in
darkness so
um okay sleeper and so what do you say
just keep going and so uh the guy uh so
Mom said why don't you just think about
uh your cousin's sleeping peacefully and
I was like that's very sweet and I did
and it helped only a little bit but what
I learned is through this stuff like
jealousy especially it's really hard to
be jealous about stuff uh when you are
focusing on things that you are grateful
about because the truth is everybody
um is walking their [ __ ] path you
know if uh if you look at
somebody who seems to have it all
they might dude I'll tell you man some
people think I have it all there are
[ __ ] weeks where I cry every single
day it's happened so it doesn't bother
no but it doesn't necessarily mean
you don't even know what you're jealous
of you don't even know what you're just
saying he's making up a narrative and
deciding that that's better than what he
has dude first of all there is what you
should do instead of being jealous is
focus on your actual goals your literal
concrete goals not what other people
already have this is like you're making
up a scenario just for you to be angry
or upset or jealous and the reason
you're doing that is because it's easier
than actually pursuing the things that
you want in the first place it's easier
to let yourself be like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
those people man I'm [ __ ] pissed it
should be me well like go make it be you
then and also let me give let me give
this guy a little bit of credit too the
fact that you even know you feel that
way and can say I'm jealous about it
even anonymously on this podcast that is
a huge step for uh growing like you know
jealous do dudes they're like nah I
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy I'm the
[ __ ] like he's not doing that he's not
doing what a typical dude does he is
saying this makes me jealous and I feel
[ __ ] let it makes me feel less then
right and that is a huge step bro so uh
I got to give you credit for that for
real because that's tough man yeah it's
the first step is always the hardest
step about this because it requires it's
not it's not just not not lying it's not
lying to yourself which is yeah it is
what you're doing which is the hardest
part dude you got to be honest with
yourself even if you don't go around
[ __ ] telling people even don't tell
anybody as long as you tell yourself the
truth it's not about being hard on
yourself it's just about being honest
with yourself a lot of myself I still
lie to myself well stop it I don't want
to stop that I try so hard okay stop
dancing maybe that's why you can't
because you're dancing when you try to
do that I don't want to lie to myself
wow that's how it begins and then you
start lying to people
you know sucks dude damn that is a dumb
way to dance huh dude it's so dumb I
hate it so much I hate it oh wait pull
up that clip of the dude pull up that
clip of the dude the car thing
dude pull up the clip of the dude oh oh
I think you know how he sent it to us oh
my god dude and he was chewing God
falling off a building
um
there it is here we go up up what was
that I don't know oh this guy where it
is there it is this is the gun was the
best
wow dude
that part dude what is he like is he
riding what is he doing he's a shopping
cart
[Music]
what a pimp dude the belt's so low the
belt's solo to accommodate his [ __ ]
dude ass hanging ass belly at a Ben's
dealership dude that guy sells 20 cars
that oh yeah dude that's what he does
when he sells a car and
um he he he's like he would literally be
20 pounds heavier If he if he didn't
sell cards
dude that's his old exercise yeah
this part
wait he doesn't like riding a tricycle
or some [ __ ] dude look how [ __ ] thick
look how thick his wallet is in the back
right pocket dude watch when he turns
around watch look how thick look how
thick so thick dude it's blank dude
no dude that's so many different
business cards right right and it's like
it's like a Hardee's card a Boston
Market card he's got a Subway punch card
yep Boston Market
dude wow guys is the worst diet too I
didn't realize my hat looked like this
holy [ __ ] boss terrible terrible
terrible you're just like one of the
guys with Fat Albert if you pull over
your eyes and cut the eyes out um all
right cool so let's do next one
my name's Sean I'm from south
Mississippi build roads here
I've got several dogs well two dogs but
anyway I'm it's because this is a
Christian Bell character I know Chris
has several dogs and I know Matt you've
probably had dogs yourself yes sir what
I'm wondering is are there too many dogs
in a household never
is there such a thing no
um how do y'all feel about different dog
breeds do you like mixed breeds or mutts
like we call them or do you like pure
breeds the necklace size everything set
of characters
just love to know what you guys think uh
Chris I can't wait to see you in
February in New Orleans hell yeah
got VIP tickets so I'm excited to I'll
meet you see you in person man very cool
take care that's so cool I will be in
New Orleans get your tickets
crystalia.com
um so here's the deal there's no such
thing as too many dogs okay the the
thing about living though in is if you
live in a city or anything over two dogs
it's like you might as well have ten one
it's great two is great three and up
dude it doesn't matter if it's [ __ ] 3
or 25 it's a pain in the [ __ ]
ass one is great two is great one is a
great dog two is a great dog's three you
have animals right but a bunch of
animals where he lives might be
different he might not be in a city I
know but so if you're not in a city and
you have land where they can run around
dude you might as well have [ __ ] as
many as you want uh as far as breeds go
I mean I'm not really that specific but
uh I think mutts will live longer and
generally they're healthier so I always
lean towards mixes of dogs because
they're less likely to get degenerative
diseases uh they're less likely to have
[ __ ] passed down from their uh you know
their bloodlines like purebred Golden
Retrievers always die before that's why
the indicator
with their family they get the [ __ ] up
knees they get the [ __ ] up backs they
get cancer a lot they get all this kind
of crazy hip dysplasia [ __ ] but that's
for two of all kinds of purebreds
they're harder to
have because they die earlier and more
painfully usually because they don't got
that [ __ ] mixed up [ __ ] that sort of
makes you healthier and better at
defending yourself from certain uh
ailments yeah mutts baby mutts baby
mutts baby mutts baby not me dude not
much I'm a purebred kind of dude all
right Aryan Nation kind of a dog guy
yeah right what Aaron Nation dog guy
well like Aryan Nation you know what
that is right yeah but you can't be that
way because they're all different kinds
of that would only be true if you only
had one kind of breed of dog I think
that the pure breed bred dogs there
should only be one that's different that
could be any kind of breed of any kind
of breed there should be one and it
should be the golden retriever and you
don't have a golden retriever I don't
know but I wish I did and if I did that
would be great but I think that there
should be one race of dog
so shitty do you call it the area nation
and every time you lose your dog it
makes sense and if you lose your dog
it's fine because you just find another
one and it looks just like yours the
world you're describing is one in which
I would not even want to be alive
that's how much I like dogs what you
heard what I said I wouldn't want to
live in that world
okay I want to live in the world where I
ho I own all the dogs I want to live in
the world where I own thousands of dogs
I have a big piece of property oh my God
I have like the amount of dogs that you
see those like aerial videos of sheep
yeah herded you know like that's the
amount of dogs I want wow all different
breeds baby every breed every breed
under the sun okay well we disagree dude
I think there should be one pure race of
dogs okay well yeah that sucks you're a
[ __ ] idiot also you have four dogs
that are all different breeds
uh so they're all mutts except for oh I
know no other ones a month two of them
are yeah Cooper's not a man no okay oh
yeah no Cooper is Cooper is yes and uh
chenzo is
shenzo's got 30 000 different strands of
uh breeding dude at chenzo ran away the
other day again he didn't mean to the
door the door was left open and the gate
was open as well didn't mean to and it
was it was it was raining and I was like
where's shenzo and I walk outside and I
looked I look down the street and he's
just running down the mountain running
down to me and people are out of their
cars like trying to get them yeah and
you're just like this
and then and then I was like come in and
he just goes and he just goes by me and
he goes in and goes in the door wow it
was so funny he used to run away and go
everywhere and we would never find him
God and this dog now just took a trip
and then came back that dog's really
something he really is something dude
he's starting to he's really starting to
love me finally really yeah finally why
because I [ __ ] try to be so gentle
with him and stuff dude dogs don't like
you the dogs dogs love me dogs never
liked you cooper cooper loves you yeah
Cooper loves me that's because Cooper
would like anybody with a piece no
Cooper loves me dude okay but my point
is every dog loves me well that's you're
just because you're like user friendly
I'm really specific and my [ __ ] is like
my [ __ ] pops when you like me you love
me right good good [ __ ] excuse uh
you're basically McDonald's and my [ __ ]
is like [ __ ] a really nice steakhouse
nobody likes McDonald's dude no I'm
saying the general public it does really
well but my [ __ ] pops like my
specifically my [ __ ] specifically pops
okay like when you know me you love me
when you know me either hate me or love
me when you you're not sure I'll have
that no no him is to love love love him
thank you Hollywood is awful no okay all
right so next one baby
and Booyah so annoying radio
from Colorado here
um I need some advice on my career so
I'm a preschool teacher cool I love it
it's amazing life rips every day I've
got 18 two and a half year olds so it's
very challenging but it's a perfect
amount of challenging for me I got my
degree in human development so oh cool
basically just geek out all this dude
that's cool
um that's not a cool joke but I don't
get paid enough money yeah okay that's
pretty typical of preschool teachers and
teachers in general I knew what I was
getting into when I started this but I'm
24 I've got time I've done retail jobs
I've done Barista I've done waitressing
like I've done it all and it's just not
as fulfilling as this job this job is
perfect it's so fulfilling it doesn't
feel like I'm going to work but I'm
really starting to feel the pressure
financially and it's very stressful I
wish I didn't have to worry about it and
I think that I should get paid more but
that's just not how the system works
right now so any advice would help thank
you for listening thank you for the
podcast and life rips I just want to
have a one thing to say before you go
okay it is a [ __ ] travesty is a
[ __ ] shame we have somebody who
studied human development and it's
[ __ ] loves being a preschool teacher
and would dedicate her entire life to it
if only she didn't get paid like [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] dude this is [ __ ] horseshit
nobody disagrees with that man I well
then why the [ __ ] is it way it is
because it's too hard out there dude
it's hot out here for a pound okay
anyway go ahead the records or whatever
um look it's
we also live in a time where you can
make money
actually kind of doing nothing okay how
would you suggest you do that look
there's a ton of ways to do it I don't
want to get into the weeds of how you
can do it but dude you can start
something online and passively make
income it is very tough to live the way
you're living because of the paycheck
you're getting but you can go home I
don't know what you have at home but you
can go home and you can learn ways to
make money just by sitting at home and
uh you could start you know
some sort of a brand some sort of a a a
a viral thing you can do this it takes
time it's very hard but you can do it
and you can get more income that way you
know you can open up a Shopify account
try and sell things you could get them
situated on the Amazon lists and all
that stuff and there's ways to make more
money I got an idea okay so and then
there's also only fans which I don't
suggest you do but like that's one way
you love your job it's just it's paying
you but it's not not paying you enough
find something that you're really good
at tip jar at the preschool oops so find
something that you're really good at and
it like set up some kind of shop online
or a way to sell it online
uh I don't know what that would be it
could be [ __ ] anything it could be
flower arrangements it could be [ __ ]
knitting it could be a graphic design I
don't [ __ ] know but find the thing
that you already have your passion Now
find the thing that you're good at and
just try to make like a little bit of
extra money at it and you will [ __ ]
the being the thing that you're really
good at and the thing that you love
doing will be this sort of like you'll
have this sort of give and take life
where yes you do the thing you love but
it doesn't pay you enough then you
[ __ ] do the thing that you're really
good at and make a little bit of extra
money that is the ideal I think for
someone like you I mean the ideal is
actually get your ass [ __ ] paid
because you deserve it but that's not
gonna [ __ ] happen uh so so what
that's the that's the advice though
always when you're like I don't know
what to do whether it's trying to find
your passion or trying to find a way to
make money
figure out the thing that you're really
really good at that you could that you
could be in a group of people and be the
best at something and then figure out
the way that that skill can be can can
lead you to make money
the thing that you're the best at is
going to be the thing that you make the
money at best most money in almost
always
yeah yeah I guess so but I don't mean
like doing cartwheels something you
could possibly monetize right cartwheel
Festival right yeah put on a date a
bi-monthly cargo Festival I don't know
what to do uh so what so what you
suggest like
like what are things like obviously
singing or like something like that or
like uh making happen
make [ __ ] the best hats dude yeah and
even if you sell just like a few a month
that's money in the bank dude that's an
additional income that is true make hats
dude
and then stop what you're doing and make
hats
worst life coach dude did you go did you
go to matalia yeah what did he tell you
to make yeah that's what you told me how
many hot companies can there be
when you're the best at it there can be
a innumerable amount of hot companies
but you're only the best if you're the
one
but then a new one comes and it's like
oh you're the best and then it's like oh
I want that kind of head not that kind
of nobody's hungrier than the wolf on
the bottom okay well you know that
doesn't apply to what uh it is true if
you're making hats and you're the top
dog all right that's great you're at the
top one more one more what video okay
but I'm saying if you're at the top okay
and you're the wolf at the top that's
great you're at the top but guess who's
hunger the wolf at the bottom okay bye
that's so rude
hi Matt and Chris
this is Anthony I am 24 doing a
monologue thank you guys for this year
for Carnegie Mellon this podcast and
I've been a fan of
Chris's
and um
I just like this I feel like confess
something making a meal you two
genuinely bring great things into
people's lives
damn it uh I'm happy and are proud
because I would be thank you all right
uh I had a question about
prioritization
I am in a situation right now where I
have I have two companies and Brian a
girlfriend who I plan to propose to
and uh I just don't have any time ever I
barely have weekends you know to spend
with her socks is mostly working
and I wanted to know if you have any uh
any tips on dealing with the stress or
dealing with
optimizing around time thank you all
right here's the thing if you got a
[ __ ] woman that you love and you're
so busy polite and you're so busy that
you really have like very little time to
ever see her you gotta make time dude
you've got to make time because she'll
[ __ ] leave you if that lasts too long
and then you'll be like why did I
[ __ ]
you gotta you gotta not let that become
an issue right you gotta make time for
her you gotta sacrifice some things even
if it's just one small thing a week that
you sacrifice you gotta make those
sacrifices dude because just like a
[ __ ] plant dude you gotta have some
water you gotta get the sun and the love
you gotta [ __ ] give the plant the son
and love you can't let it wither away
and not feed it you gotta [ __ ] you
gotta keep it moist you gotta keep it
nice soft and moist and sunny and light
look at my plant still no I don't
remember what
um uh yeah you gotta you got two
companies that's cool balling out of
control but also not balling out of
control with you you got to be bowling
out of control companies I get it but if
you don't make time for your girl your
girl's gonna be balling out of control
and I don't mean balling money I mean
balling crying right wow so she could be
balling out of control because you're
balling out of control so you got to get
your balls kind of controlled oh wow you
can't be really out of control you got
to be more balling in control so your
girl's not balling at all right so we
got to get Ballin in control to make
sure your girl is not balling at all and
that is the platform I'm running on vote
for me so the easier way to say that is
just you got it you've got to make time
for your girl yeah you will regret it if
you don't but sounds like you really
really love this woman obviously you're
going to propose to her you're gonna
propose gotta [ __ ] make sure it's
you gotta you gotta dedicate time dude
so just like anything else so Matt said
obviously make time for her if I'm gonna
say it the easier way the more memorable
way you're balling out of control but
pretty soon your girlfriend's gonna be
balling out of control and I don't mean
balling with money I mean balding crying
right so you got to be balling more in
control this way your woman is not
bawling at all and that's the way to say
it so you're just literally saying the
same exact thing that you just said yeah
because okay because you said it the way
where it's like make more time for your
girl but me I'm saying it the important
way which is
your ball in control
and you shouldn't be you know and you
gotta you gotta make sure you're bowling
in control your girl's gonna be balling
out of control and I don't mean bowling
with money I mean balling crying so I
got to be more balling in control so she
won't be balling at all stop
do you know what I mean just [ __ ]
completely stop all right
that wraps up the episode thank you all
so much if you want one-on-one uh advice
sessions with me Matt Delia uh I do them
from 1 30 to 5 30 Pacific Time on
Tuesdays and Thursdays book at
mattdelia.com and if you have a question
click the link in the description below
or just go to watch
lifeline.com and if you want that merch
baby merch lifelinemerch.com that's
right and also I'll be in Austin and New
York and also Chicago and also Tulsa and
a bunch of different places like Midland
Texas so go to chrysler.com and get your
tickets
mm-hmm
hello hello hello hello
[Music]